speaking of insane Don Lemon CNN go
the police are identifying the shooter
as a trans woman would actually be a
trans man so that's sort of a
misidentification there but this is all
new I'm just wondering the identity of
being a transgender person and also
being identified as a woman does this
pose any sort of difference or
difficulty for the for police because
it's not typically a woman regardless of
how they are identifying so there are a
couple of things here that are different
and that we are going to have to talk
about and delve into
right so each of these cases is always
going to have a particular difference
right whether it's uh someone is angry
at their father or someone had something
happen at the school and this is a
unique case and we have to be sensitive
about it to the extent that Audrey Hale
identified as a woman we do not see Mass
Shooters who are female especially in
particular school shooting uh murderers
those that is that is uh uh this is
actually I think the first time that I
can remember
okay do you see how they're so focused
on the wrong thing and how they are
making they're basically running cover
for a trans ideology because if this was
a Muslim that went into a church and
shot Christians nobody would be like oh
we better figure this out but everyone
would be and and probably correctly well
first off I would still say there's a
mental health issue because again if you
kill innocent people there's a mental
health issue there but we would be able
to maybe connect this to a religious
ideology and there would be a certain
amount of people by the way people on
the right who then would be unjustly
prejudiced against Muslims if a
Christian shooter went into a Jewish
synagogue or a Jew went into a mosque
right we would be able to somewhat
clearly connect these things but in this
one we better not misgender this person
as a trans man or a trans woman this has
never happened before we should be very
careful as opposed to focusing on the
real victims the way they talk about it
the victim here is the is the shooter
the victim here is the shooter you know
because you know the daily wires in
Nashville and uh you know somebody
misgendered this guy or this gal
insane absolutely insane
[Music]